hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play my
eternal nightmare SCP condemned everyt
okay we got our little room with our
friend our friendly friend um I forget
his SCP designation but then again I
don't care he's just kind of there so
we're just gonna go around him and nah
the same to be locked but it's open need
to close that door hi
hi thank you goodbye forever go away go
to hell there we go okay that is locked
and I can't see booth okay whatever
whatever whatever man
hey you back off you son of a [ __ ]
okay now we just need to look at the
ground again and make our way into that
room nothing gonna stop us now to root
oh that's a chair
hahaha I love those em okay here we go
power feed umm generator what did that
do what did that do what did it do oh
well whatever okay there's some on this
wall no okay whatever let's just guy
here I don't want to be here anymore
Oh
oh those that close that close it
incredibly
you know I did look it up
there's no way I did not look at him
ah
okay I didn't look at him looking at the
ground memory access violation screw you
getting back in the game it's gonna take
a while cuz it low it takes a while to
load up in the beginning I shouldn't
take too long
whoas a debuff wraps in three two one
and oh is that about I wasn't looking at
him Oh son I start hearing the ha ha ha
yeah good okay I'm done okay no anyway
let's uh that apparently didn't do
anything so it seems to be locked
let's um try this again except this time
I'm going to be facing away from him
every single time we hang on this door
is open now but I think one seven threes
on the other side of it is hey buddy
okay shave here okay okay you can't get
through that door but I gotta get I
didn't do it now this door is now seems
to be locked
okay so what I need to do is I need to
get these things working ah the hell
fuel pump is on save so I don't look at
them what does this switch do maybe I
need to maybe I need to engage this
after I turn on backing up very slowly
ah I'm stuck on it oh I thought it was
him just the door just the door get the
door get the door okay we're good
we're good we're good okay then I need
to flip this to the generator and then
hit that power switch maybe back up back
up back up back up
I got back up okay we're good we're good
he doesn't even exist in my mind well
that didn't do anything well piss now
this open hood
close go go go back up close it save it
take it off ha no thank you that was
horrifying
goddamn I forget what his SCP number is
douche McGee they're gonna be radical
Larry here I would really rather not
deal with him uh he just give me the
heebie-jeebies he's like the worst one I
swear that is nightmare fuel right there
like man do you see his face no matter
where are you oh you gotta stop that man
nice guys
[ __ ] that's a six eight two's
containment area my frame rate dropped
for some reason I don't know why okay
it's back to normal or anyway nope it's
back down there there's something over
here
it is causing my framerate to drop what
is this oh this is all yeah that's the
basement area where 173 is camping out
hello is this oh this is the electrical
center okay this is where I need to go
if I wanted to leave through gate B but
I've already done that I don't want to
turn all that off just yet this is new
was this it's a more different hallway
it's very quiet in here okay it was
nothing it's just the newly textured
walls are throwing me off a bit come on
all right save hm
I'm okay just these new walls are kind
of messing with me what do we got oh
come on I don't want to go down there
yes this is where he is is he darling
you may not be down here this time
what the hell is that Jesus
god damn hi Oh piss ah oh man I fell
through the floor gotta go back up oh oh
come on go straight up straight up
straight up straight up straight up not
forward straight up come on there we go
there we go there we go okay all right
now I'm not gonna cheat I'm not gonna
cheat through this even though I could I
could and I want to where is he
okay all right he's in here
he's down here somewhere I just don't
know where and he's gonna magically pop
up behind me for no particular reason
cuz he's a dick
what is that the hell is that can where
is he where is he I heard that where is
he where is he where is he oh you're the
we get away get away get away get away
get away get away get away get away stay
down there you bastard you know there Oh
No it made me go in a circle
that was totally useless that didn't
help me at all that was a complete
circle that is unbook you son of a [ __ ]
you know it wasn't a complete search
this is different area okay I thought it
was for a zoning there it looked exactly
alike
I swear did
okay I swear it I was about to lose it
yep what's in here
why is it all red ah gate a this should
be locked up
yes locked up but gate a is probably one
of the new endings was this hello wait
what is this hey let me see here
oh I didn't expect this to work wait is
gate a gate a is the one the computer
sends you right where am I going oh wait
a minute the computer didn't send me
this way but this isn't right
something's gone wrong something's gone
horribly wrong because radical area is
not showing up right now haha oh no this
isn't good uh all right
I didn't do anything I give up I
surrender
okay then let's um go this way hey
buddies don't mind me oh hi you don't
see anything you don't see [ __ ] what the
hell it seems to be locked
oh no you stop right there no you stop
no you stop ah someone is trying to
shoot me whoo easy okay so I was not
since I was not supposed to go there
I would not both do any of that ha ha ha
ha ha ha I was not supposed to do that
at all ok let's save that for another
day why is it brighter in here - what
the hell it suddenly got a lot brighter
in here which is good I don't mind it
might be borrowing the luminosity from
the outside area and my framerate is
tanking oh oh classic signs of a crash
in pending the sons of peach ha ha it's
actually really nice in here now it's
late and a lady it's bright and shiny
although the framerate is suffering at
least I can see hi hi there
you gonna go away now you're turning
around aren't you no no oh we want to
follow me through this odd Tesla gate
hey buddy how about it
hey friend you won't come over here got
something for you
looks like you're stuck on another one
sorry about the lies coming go go go go
go go okay come on come on you [ __ ]
come on come on go much time here tank
out come on come on little buddy what
you go oh what you got I've never killed
one of these guys in Tesla Gate but I
know you can
where did he go I'm right here I'm not
anywhere ah [ __ ] I've uh
I don't know why I did that
here's to opposition Oh No
oh I thought you could just I thought on
never mind
oh never mind I don't know what the hell
I'm doing I have no clue ah I'm just
[ __ ] around here I don't know how I'm
gonna be able to get past those guys
maybe if I like reload I reload the
level by going outside and why is my
frame rates Ocean it snit why is it so
she'd like my frame rates the bed
I have supercomputer it should not be
these days
hi hi how you doing buddy you doing good
you doing good you're doing good you
look good how's the family
good yeah you don't need to kill me I'm
just a Class B that means class doable
awesome
you don't need to kill me I didn't I
didn't go to jail or anything murder no
not me
like I can crash remember right yeah ah
you can't see me I'm hiding I'm hidden
I'm still see like moose don't know
about your friend there but I am still T
oh oh you're you're stupid no I'm not
you shut up I'm sneaking I'm sneaking
move your fat ass
you move your fat ass I am trying to
sneak out of building you are son of
[ __ ] you know that you are son of [ __ ]
I closed the door on you now I cut you
in half it seems to be largely
unaffected
well this sucks
we know you didn't see anything come on
through
it's a bright sunshiny day dicks okay I
don't know what I'm gonna do about that
but I'll figure it out I may just have
to noclip around him so anyway shut up
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation more videos that I've
done and as always I'll see you shut up
in the next video bye